but his mom was like hyper abusive
towards him
like if i kind of read the kind of [ __ ]
that she would say to him because he
wrote in his autobiography it's [ __ ]
terrible
but he he was 13 and he had he got some
weed
from an older homie who was like his
brother like he looked up to this guy
right
and he laced his [ __ ] like on training
day yeah and that's how he got hooked on
drugs
wow and apparently he got him into rap
too right like that yeah so he
he was rapping and um that that became
his his mentor because they saw promise
in him right
and so he he went through in five four
three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain podcast
i am your host david so we have nick the
quick ear here
nick the mouth the other day and i was
like what does that mean why did you
talk too much
you'd be sucking them dicks yeah but
like have you ever tried
no would you no honestly would you no
it's like someone's dick
i think out of everybody here you'd be
the one yeah we have this guy
remember we had a whole conversation
about like would you rather take it in
the butt
or suck somebody off i'm i'm team taking
in the butt all the way
over sucking oh that's not that's weird
dude that is gonna be like this
i'm bringing it back i think the thing
is i can prep that you know what i mean
i can't see you blowing a guy like
because
oh thanks man wait wait no i can't see
me wait wait because you're gay i feel
like it's because you're so nice and you
want to just help out
yeah you want to give your partner like
their training program like oh it'll
help you lose weight okay
sign up for coaching with me baby i'm
having a bad day like i'm having a bad
day like
you're all just yeah it's like it's like
a pre-workout i see you sucking that
guy's dick
i still can't see me taking it up the
butt though i'd rather suck the dick
because i'm in control this is my dick
putting something in your mouth is very
intimate i think that's
something on your butt
hey some people have different standards
my man like you know because i can just
i can compartmentalize and just look off
into space while someone's just
[ __ ] plowing yeah when your ass is so
disrespectful though huh yeah bro
have you ever had anything up your butt
though these cheeks tight nah so you
gotta make them bust quick is what
you're saying yeah like these cheeks bro
this this whole
time yeah but when you're when you're
sucking somebody's dick though you can
control how fast they come so you can
make it quick
you could like fast but you gotta enjoy
it though like you gotta like you know
and also if you gotta put some effort
into it like i gotta put some effort in
the [ __ ] second one
but wait with the dicks at least like
what is this if they get crazy you have
like you can squeeze ball you know what
yeah yeah
like get too aggressive hey and then
he's like oh [ __ ] you know like
he's really in control here you know i'm
not into that
you're all like you're done there is a
sense of domination of just getting
[ __ ] in the ass you know
yeah dude look someone's sucking
someone's dick like
you grab the balls you're getting
smashed and then your dick is hitting
your belly button
oh bro i'm i'm taping it back so there's
none of that
what are you talking about bro this
guy's never been plowed in the ass
before
like an amateur hour double-sided tape
on the top
see see this is the this is how you know
david's a pro double-sided tape most
people think just regular i'm a parts
and craft person that's why
this podcast is brought to you by scotch
double-sided you ever getting plowed in
the ass
you started doing stand-up again i did
he's been doing this podcast for [ __ ]
seven years now yeah come on now guys
come on bro
how was that look i did bro it was fun i
was so scared honestly
so nervous that i had pain in my chest
like legit pain in my chest how i was
trying to become
your first show uh it's been like over a
year yeah that's over here bro
and i was like i was like all the you
know the mental battle before you get on
stage like no i can do this i've done
this before bro
but then there's this other voice like
now you're gonna bomb and no one's gonna
your friends are all gonna not talk to
you every day
why did you only direct that question to
david like you didn't direct it to me at
all
like i'm sitting in the room too um
but yeah dude so that fighting that boy
that weird voice that's like tells you
it's just gonna be like a plane's gonna
crash in your house uh
but once i got on stage i had a couple
drinks too so that helped out a little
bit
to calm down but once i got up there i
felt [ __ ]
i felt like i got better honestly from
the layoff because like before i felt
like i was kind of stuck in my material
and
kind of dumb just like a routine and i
realized i was putting too much pressure
on my shows to like
to they all had to be like killer shows
and it wasn't giving me the freedom to
be loose and trying new things
so i at that now it's like i was like
brand new again i was like [ __ ] it like
i don't get what am i going to talk
about i just kind of went up rift crowd
work and then did a couple jokes here
and there and it was great like i felt
[ __ ] really good damn and it kind of
just reignited the
the fire like oh i can't wait to get on
stage again
what's your next show i don't have one
right now all right
all right all right
must have been a great show well so like
why don't you do a show with pat once
you hop on the next show cause it's i
here's one thing that i don't want to do
i don't want to do stand up with a with
a half crowd
and plus like with this podcast crowd
having [ __ ]
well it's because of right now you can't
fill up the spot oh yeah that's true
that's true it's still but honestly on
the on the flip side
it's like why not like it's kind of very
low stakes you know
so you can walk with a paycheck i could
walk away with something yeah yeah
that's true okay i got you i got you
what are you trying to do jokes uh no
not really i did a couple like i did a
lot of crowd work because they weren't
really listening it was a rough crowd
that was what i was gonna tell you it's
like
they weren't like it was a long show and
there was some of the comics were like
and then they were just not really
paying attention so i had to go out
there and like
bust their balls and talk [ __ ] to them
it's like kind of starting a fire right
it's like if they're not listening
it takes a while like you don't just go
boom when there's a fire you got to like
do
chip at it chip at it blow on it chip
chip blow blow and then they all start
kind of listening and then you start
doing your jokes and then they're on
board
so the mic types were so hard dude like
because nobody's listening right well it
depends on when you go up
right and sometimes better comics come
in they'll push you back push you back
and then you're at the point where
everybody's [ __ ] exhausted and even
you're tired
yeah yeah and then you're trying to do
your set because the build up right and
also there's there's
it's like negative energy yeah there's
just like neutral energy and then
there's
negative like dark hole energy and
that's what open mics are yeah yep
all the time it's like just like like it
hurts to be in there it's like
you remember in dragon ball z where they
were trained in the gravity chambers and
it was like 200.
it's like that it's like you're like on
the phone just dating you is painful
so yeah open mics are [ __ ] brutal
because everybody always says like for
open mics it's like
because it's mostly comedians in there
right like other comedians so they're
all like they're not listening to you
they're just thinking about what the
[ __ ] they're going to say
sometimes yeah that's the thing but the
thing is you just have to
learn how to get like it's you're not
gonna don't don't expect a standing
ovation you know like
just kind of see what it's just a good
it's like hitting a bag that's what i
equate it to it's like [ __ ] it like i'm
just gonna throw my punches because it's
like part of it is just
so you can hear yourself saying it too
and you feel the rhythm of the joke
because like even when i'm up there and
whatever the reaction is i can kind of
feel while i'm talking like i'm taking
too long like this is taking too long to
get to something funny and then that's a
note for me to go back and edit it you
know or
this is like a little unclear you know
like so it still serves a purpose
even though it's [ __ ] brutal are all
comedy clubs open again now
i don't think all of them are yet i know
i think the haha opened up
they're doing outdoor stuff i don't know
what's up with the ice house i think the
comedy store might be doing some outdoor
or they do drive-in stuff right now
i feel like after june because everybody
should have
well majority of people should have a
shot now yeah i think june is the moment
that everybody's going to open up and
it's going to be back to normal
yeah yeah because the hard part was a
lot of stand-up comics they
the ones that only do stand up for a
living they got [ __ ] yeah like
yeah what the [ __ ] were they gonna do
for a living after this because it was
literally they had all the
[ __ ] booked and it was just gone they
didn't they weren't doing movies they're
not acting
they don't have a side job or a side
hustle this is how they paid their bills
and
it just disappeared overnight yeah if
they didn't have a podcast or whatever
or something else ringing in an income
then yeah they were
like what the [ __ ] are they supposed to
do at that point i i feel like the
outdoor stuff too is kind of hard
because even if you're outdoors you're
so spread apart
the setting is weird yeah and laughing
too is contagious so it's like the table
next to you is laughing it makes you
want to laugh there are times where i'm
in the company club and i clearly don't
like this guy set but there's somebody
next to me is laughing and i'm like
yeah exactly you know i'm like i guess
it's funny [ __ ] i don't know
maybe i'm an
you know and so you kind of there's that
synergy that's gone yeah yeah right
absolutely and also distractions i mean
a car like
like in the middle of your punch line or
like a dog just taking a [ __ ] over there
it's just like
there's a lot of things going on where
you like constantly have to like wrangle
them back in you know you know the last
time when we had the podcast i was
supposed to upload that [ __ ] episode
yeah let me just tell you something
because i knew i was going to hawaii i
was
out to [ __ ] lunch so i only recorded
your audio
his mic and my mic were off and the
video was bro
this podcast was fire it was like good
that might have been some of our best
work but
this pool didn't start the camera i
didn't film it
when when i found out the audio wasn't
there either uh-huh
you should have heard the amount of
cursing in this room how the [ __ ]
[ __ ] i was so pissed i had a feeling bro
so it sounded like i was having a
conversation with myself is that what it
sounded like like it was just like
something
like this you just hear this like this
this faint voice in the background it
just goes
and then you go haha
and i was just so pissed i was like i
remember this one being so
[ __ ] funny yeah but then i just
that's the first time i didn't before
the fire
audio and the [ __ ] video dude so i
don't know what happened but that week
was a little weird
vacation mode hawaii mode is different
though hawaii and there's hawaii mode
and there's vacation mode
i've been to hawaii once and i just know
that i'm an expert now
it's the greatest place on earth i told
you hawaii was great it's the it's
i don't want to go anywhere else but
hawaii you know what i mean
and it's in and it's in the u.s i don't
have to [ __ ] go through customs and i
could just fly over to hawaii
and do the paradise the whole corona
virus thing before you
to get checked before you go into hawaii
was giving me mad anxiety
same right i was like oh i'm going to be
quarantined i'm recording for 10 days
like what was it
so 72 hours before you have to get a
test
to make sure that you don't have corona
right but they don't tell you how fast
you're gonna get it
it can be it's a period of you can get
it in a day or four days well if it goes
four days
you're [ __ ] you're gonna be
quarantined because you need to get
those tests before you fly out oh so
everybody got their [ __ ] but me so i'm
like well here it is i'm gonna go to
[ __ ] hawaii in a hotel for eight days
oh my god so i was getting super nervous
but the day before it came in
oh my god damn that's scary yep
so it's eight days mandatory like if you
don't get ten days ten days man
and then how long were you there for
like i was there for eight days so you
would have
had us you would have missed your flight
to get back 100
i also found out that i have something
called a sun allergy
what yeah like i haven't made that
i forgot what the acronym is but i have
it
i have a sun allergy where uh my skin is
sensitive to uv rays
so i guess like out in la it's not that
strong the uv rays right because i'm out
biking all the time whenever we're
training in parks i'm okay
but uh in the past like five or six
years i've been going to hawaii i
assumed that the [ __ ] that i was getting
was like a diaper rash it was like a
heat rash okay so when you have wet
clothes or whatever you know babies get
that [ __ ]
but um it didn't make sense because i
was getting rashes where it was exposed
to light and i'm like what the [ __ ] like
it's not wet here so why would i get
this rash
yeah um they got red right yeah so you
get you get raised bumps like you can
even see some of the
the bumps right here where i was
scratching at it but
it's if when i go into uv light it
causes a like an allergic rash like you
get it's not hives but it's bumps all
over your body
and so uh the only way to cure it is
through constant exposure to uv light
so for seven [ __ ] days i was wrecked
and then on the eighth day when i'm
leaving it all disappeared
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] that means you
gotta go back to hawaii for another i am
i'm actually going back on the 25th
[ __ ] and you can't do that here you
can't get that uv well the uv light here
is not as strong as the [ __ ] in hawaiian
sun is different bro
what i love about hawaii too like half
the people that are [ __ ] fat so it
doesn't even matter bro
i'm out there i'm like they're like hey
man you're really fit i'm like yeah yeah
bodybuilder what's
i'm telling you man like hawaii is super
chill nobody gives a [ __ ] out there it's
the best
it's so chill it is really chill like
the only people who care about like
their physical
if you're in waikiki everywhere else
people were just chilling there was this
one kid that looked just like me just
dark as [ __ ] he was just like hey
i'm a big fan i'm like bro you fat as
[ __ ] just like me man hey
the best of waikiki is all like the big
samoan kids that just jump
off the the little uh i don't know what
it is like the the giant like rock
and these kids are just like they're
anywhere from five years old all the way
to like
15 they could be 20 i don't know they
all some of them look really [ __ ] old
with these giant like hawaiian kids and
they're big as [ __ ] and they just jump
off and they just splat they just do
like cannonballs and stuff it's a good
time i just like watching people have
fun
you didn't you didn't do it yourself
what the [ __ ] you didn't do it yourself
no you didn't you just stood next to the
rock watching them you know being tipped
were sitting for far away we're just
people watching and then we're just like
wow why don't you jump off
because it was like those big old flat
feet of yours you would have jetted
right through the water
yeah bro you know it's like i am a
pretty good swimmer but like you know
whatever
but yeah it's just like it seems like
their thing and i was like you know this
is my first day in hawaii and i was like
i have plenty
i have plenty of days you did nothing
did you jump off any cliffs
no cliffs jumping's so fun it's so scary
though yeah i jumped off
when i was in hawaii i jumped off the
highest thing i've ever jumped off in my
[ __ ] life it took me like two hours
to work up the courage to actually
do it it was like this little cove
and i actually left i didn't do it i
like left and i got back in the car
i was with jose and his wife and i sat
in the car
and i felt like such a [ __ ] i was like
oh wow such a [ __ ] for not doing that
like
and jose was giving me [ __ ] i ended up
yelling at jose because jose was trying
to encourage me like shut the [ __ ] up
i'm just so scared it was a maui and
then that yeah and then
we got in the car was just quiet and i
was like [ __ ] that i was like i got it i
have to do it i was like i feel
miserable right now and then we like ran
back i just
went up there and didn't even think
about it jumped [ __ ]
so sick it was so fun but water shot
like up my ass
yeah yeah you have to close your legs my
legs look more like this
but i think i went like this but i kind
of like
my body kind of like went like this oh
yeah so it was like i literally landed
like on my [ __ ]
kind of and it was just like like i felt
like water and like i was like oh
well you're lucky you didn't get the
ball smacked dude yeah i didn't get the
ball i got the ball smacked
so in maui there's this place i think
it's called turtle cove or something
like that but
there's a clip of me actually doing the
cliff dive well we did it
all of us did it together right here
your balls slapping on that one well i
[ __ ] you have a couple of options you
can dive or you could pencil dive right
which is just
straight down so i did the same thing
had my legs slightly open
and it just somebody just [ __ ] street
fighter uppercutted me right in the ball
oh my god dude
[ __ ] bad and also too if you go deep
you also have to make sure
well i'm heavier too so you best believe
i touched that sea floor
i took that floor straight down there
dude this podcast is brought to you by
skillshare my friends if you're out
there and there's a skill that you want
to learn skillshare has it
for you i love skillshare i have been
using it for
just about everything from editing all
the way to like photography
and just some skills that out i just
want to learn on my own
and i know for a lot of you out there
like traditional learning such as in a
university for specific hobbies or
maybe even a side hustle that you want
to do you don't want to go to a full
university for you just want to get the
courses that that'll teach you what you
need one of the courses that i'm taking
right now is actually productivity for
creatives because as a creative
productivity is not my biggest specialty
it's to be creative but being organized
is the hard part where sometimes it's
hard to kind of push out content
if i don't know how to be productive
with my time and so this course has been
saving my ass
skillshare by the way if you guys didn't
know if you're thinking that it's super
expensive it's not
it is super affordable an annual
subscription
is less than ten dollars a month i'm
serious
so explore your creativity at
skillshare.com
brain and get a free trial of premium
membership that's skillshare.combrain
once again go to skillshare.com brain
and get a free trial of premium
membership today that's skillshare.com
brain because nobody told me that when
you pisses out you can open up to slow
it down
[ __ ] i kept it stiff all the way
down
you can't be too safe one degree of you
just like being forward
[ __ ] you up especially when you're
jumping from that high [ __ ] that how
would you know
you were a little [ __ ] you didn't do it
i just did we just didn't go anywhere
and who wouldn't want poseidon in his
ass well on today's topic in news we
have to talk about segways
bro we have to talk about dmx passing
away
r.i.p baby i wanted to i was i'm not
sure if he passed away when i was in
hawaii no
i was here it was like a couple days ago
i think that's right officially right
but he was
he was he od'd and he went into coma so
i heard
so many different things yeah there's a
lot going on he died people were saying
that
it was because he got vaccinated that
was a rumor too
i don't know who said this but it just
becomes part of the story
somebody wrote a rumor said that his
family said that it was from the vaccine
and then initial reports were that he
overdosed from drugs
yeah and like got a heart attack was
brain dead then they said he wasn't
wasn't brain dead but his organs were
failing
all this [ __ ] but people are willing
to blame anything on the vaccine
yeah i don't he doesn't look like he
takes vaccines at all yeah
like i'm sorry he doesn't like him
has the the [ __ ] cure for rona inside
of him you know
100 i didn't i didn't realize he's only
50 dude yeah he was young super [ __ ]
young man
did you guys listen to dmx when you were
younger yeah like i mean just the the
you know the ones that we all know i
never went in deep
yeah heavy hitters i you know i just i
liked him more as an actor personally
like i was more
interested in nobody ever yeah what
romeo almost died
over the grave i remember that those are
the movies i saw him i already did like
a back flip off a wall or something
and like kick steven seagal on the side
beating the shot at everybody bro exit
wounds
exit wounds stevenson is such a clown
bro
idiot dude if you're wearing orange
tinted glasses
and it's not a joke and you're not at a
shooting range
you're you're you're a clown that guy
have you heard of all those funny ass
stories about steven seagal from like
not also say rob dirdick but who's the
guy that's in uh the adam sandler camp
rob deer dick i'm not rob durdeck you
[ __ ] face uh rob schneider
rob schneider oh really yeah so rob
schneider he tells his funny ass [ __ ]
story
literally where did he get rob tear dick
oh i get the same name yeah yeah
that's why you dumb ass he literally
just said wrong
said it out loud yeah steven seagal has
a similar he has
everybody every celebrity that has met
steven sengal has a weird [ __ ] story
about him yeah so rob schneider talks
about the story where
uh they were on a movie set together and
they were
uh on a boat right and so
there was all of his movies are on a
boat by the way he's like all those
stevens and golf movies are a [ __ ]
boat for like a long story short there
was like a false door
that was connected to the boat that
doesn't lead to anywhere but the ocean
he should [ __ ] know this [ __ ] right
so [ __ ] this guy somehow goes through
the fall store and falls straight into
the ocean
[ __ ] tries to play it off he
says that when he gets out of the
[ __ ] water
the paint that he put in to fill his
hair was dripping down all the way down
his [ __ ] face
this guy is so weird i actually have a
friend of mine who worked on one of his
shitty ass movies
and they were doing sound for him right
this [ __ ] is so [ __ ] hilarious like
steven segal is such an
[ __ ] this is a movie that he funded
himself
his own film that he's funding himself
okay and in every film that steven
seagal does
there's one thing that he does he's he's
always a hero of course of course he has
mad [ __ ] [ __ ]
and he beats everybody up and nobody
touches him yeah no matter what film it
is even though he's like 80 years old
and he's fat as [ __ ] now yeah
so in this movie he [ __ ] up all of his
lines because he mumbles his [ __ ] he's a
terrible [ __ ] actor
yeah but he's always very stoic yeah he
squints his eyes a lot
exactly so he has to he has to do adr
for his stuff right so he has to voice
over work to fill in his stuff
so in his own film he comes in the the
the sound guy is there this is from a
friend who does sound
he's there and they're supposed to
record him right he does the takes
terribly he goes all right stephen so we
have to do this take again he goes i
only do one
his own movie this is his movie this is
not something that he got hired for and
he walks out and leaves
and it's trash so the director had to
hire
a voice actor to come in and do steven
seagal's voice
so they had a wow a professional voice
actor redo steven seagal's voice
they do it they get it done right they
the director comes back pissed he goes
what the [ __ ] is this they go well the
guy did the lies he goes i know
the guy said the line's too perfect
steven mumbles like redo it but do it
shittier
this guy's [ __ ] weird he's a weirdo
and now that she pointed out
i don't think i've ever seen a darker
black than steven seagals his hair
his hair that is the the darkest black
you could ever get
so i had to look it up so he's one of
the first american people to ever
open up an akito like dojo in the states
or something okay so he's actually
accredited he's very legit
yeah like aikido is a very weird type of
martial art where
it was it was developed as like uh
a martial life for defense to disarm
somebody like samurai like swords
so how does that really apply to to
fighting now right besides wrist locks
and tosses because it mixes them with a
little bit of judo
but like steven segal when you remember
when he was talking about how he taught
anderson silva like the front kick that
knocked him i told him
i told him to do that and i cheated too
when he knocked out ryan couture so he
did exactly what i told him
he angles for credit more than anybody
i've ever heard of in my life i taught
him secret techniques
yeah yeah no one's ever seen imagine
like because odeon cormier talks about
this
darren cormier is like an olympic
caliber wrestler
like one of the greatest fighters of all
time he goes up to this dude and goes
hey let me show you something before
your fight before he fought i think uh
it was like anderson silva or somebody
big or jon jones
and then dan cormier doesn't talk about
like what he showed him but he just was
like
yeah like this dude pulled me aside and
was trying to like teach me some [ __ ] to
do for the fight
imagine going up to a guy like daniel
daniel cormier one of the greatest
fighters of all time he's a narcissist
he's weird dude he's so weird i forgot
what he was saying but it was anderson
silva fighting somebody else but he was
taking credit for training both of them
so he goes these are my children these
are my chill i can't
i can't watch my kids fight
nobody looks at you like you're their
dad like [ __ ] out of him what a [ __ ]
loser
is probably laughing his way to the
[ __ ] bank he's an actual you know
he's a sheriff
[ __ ] [ __ ] and like the moment he
talks to a black person it's it's what's
up my brother
hey what's up bro it's game on dude
what's going on pimpy
what's going on hey you can't be doing
that stuff around here you're going to
lose your goddamn mind
like if i've ever seen the most racist
[ __ ] i've ever seen it'd be like my man
dmx you know dmx i'm going to talk like
this
well your auntie with that sweet tea
yo somebody stops steven seagal right
now he's talking to himself he's talking
in characters
there's an actual clip of him doing that
[ __ ] it's nuts i heard he'd be like
bound to like chinese people with asian
people and [ __ ]
this dude is so [ __ ] out of his i
tried watching he had a movie on netflix
it was like where he's in iraq or
something
and it's like literally just detroit you
know it's like literally it's so low
budget it's like
downtown it's like not the middle east
like joshua yeah you see like a [ __ ]
circus city sign in the back and [ __ ]
and it's so bad bro but it's so funny
it was so i watched i got through like
half of it but i wish i was high i was
like i should smoke weed and watch this
again
because it was so god damn ridiculous
everything is made
to glorify him everything is so he is a
literal god in all of his films like
when he comes to the room
everybody recognizes his greatness and
then he always does his aikido flip [ __ ]
and chops people in the neck and they
all die
yeah immediately there has there been a
bigger [ __ ] than that no
100 no like he's got to be top
three biggest [ __ ] of all time ever
who's a bigger [ __ ] than him uh it
could be uh
jean-claude van damme and blood sport
not evil
like physique wise look like jean-claude
van damme he would be doing the same
[ __ ] too
i think he used to be he's [ __ ] tall
he's like six foot six or something is
he he's a giant stevens ago he's tall
he's like a solid three or four inches
taller than me damn
yeah he's a big [ __ ] guy that's crazy
that makes me want to talk less [ __ ]
about stephen cigar have you seen the
compilation of steven segal running
no i
there is okay and that's that's when you
put the guild theme song behind it
yeah i literally typed in steven seagal
first thing that came up right give us
the gallbladder yeah yeah put it on
the music the drumsticks yo this is
steven seagal [ __ ] running dude
he looked like that for like two looks
like gumby bro yeah
what the [ __ ] he has never ran in his
life he's like woody running in toy
story he looks like woody dude
he looks like the team america puppets
he has never jogged or ran in his life
why is he swinging his hands like that i
don't know he's like swings his hands
like in his mind he probably thinks he's
killing it oh sure
he's like damn i'm dope this is funny
because all these running scenes is all
from one movie
it's all one movie it kind of talks like
donald j trump too like his characters
yeah yeah and like the cadence of how he
says it too it's like he
it's very slow and he kind of like
stretches out his words a little bit
kind of like mike perry mike perry talks
like that too oh my shout out to my
parents last fight dude
i didn't watch it but [ __ ] you want to
watch a [ __ ] boxing clinic
yeah you got his face dude it was bad
yeah well i like that dude he's crazy
but i like him and i feel bad that he
keeps getting inside it's weird because
when you listen to his like post fight
conference
he was talking about um how different
his mindset is now that he has a kid
yeah he's all calm and smooth and this
is the worst he's ever looked at a fight
the worst didn't move his head is all
his legs were stiff as [ __ ] he was
getting pieced
up is his girlfriend still his his coach
i don't i don't think so no i didn't see
him
he doesn't he still doesn't have a coach
um yeah that's a problem bro that's a
big
problem dude yeah is he uncoachable you
can't be your own boss
he just doesn't want to give him money
or something he thinks that it's like
they're just trying to rip them off but
he sucks so what are you talking about
he's got trash
issues he came back from uh winkle john
like uh
jackson winkle john yeah as soon as he
came back from that camp he just was
like
that's when he started doing like i
ain't gonna have no coach but he needs a
coach
he needs a needs a coach you go train
with darren till darren till was like
come train with me he's like
he's got to be dope yeah he was like
i'll put you up room and board bro just
come train with us
you should i'll put you and your family
up my team would be happy to do
something that live of them did you see
the live of them talking [ __ ] to each
other no the girls
it's so funny and it makes you feel it
like made me feel good
like happy oh for real happy and funny
as [ __ ] they were on live just talking
[ __ ] to each other for like 20 minutes
you go it's [ __ ] hilarious mike
perry's like yo i'll [ __ ]
i'll kick your mom in the [ __ ] head
and [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of her you [ __ ]
idiot
and you go and the dare tells like
laughing he's like yo i'll [ __ ] knock
you
out i would knock your your jaw clean
off and put my dick in your mouth
like just crazy they're talking about or
do they hate each other i don't know
i think now they well based off that
because it goes from that
to them kind of just discussing mma and
darren till kind of
genuinely being like hey i want to
actually see you do good come train with
me
so i think now they kind of like each
other i think darren's like because
darren so from his point of view he's
like yo
we're homies like we're cool like we we
would before the quarantine
well actually during the quarantine he
would text mike perry and he goes hey
let's just start talking some [ __ ]
everyone's bored at home no one's doing
anything let's just start talking on
twitter
yeah and they were like all right cool
so they would just go back and forth
like [ __ ] around saying like oh
you're a [ __ ] i'll knock you out yada
yada yeah just like fun stuff
and then apparently darren till was like
oh i'll raw dog your girl like shut up
about raw dog or girl because you just
got a new girlfriend
yeah and then ever since that he like
blocked him on everything
didn't hit him up and he's like yo what
the [ __ ] i thought we were doing
something like
i was just [ __ ] around and then i
guess that's when he said that's when
mike perry said i'll [ __ ]
kick your mom in the face and [ __ ] her
or something like and he goes dude he
said that
like what the [ __ ] like it's all good
we're talking [ __ ] like darren till
doesn't have a boundary like yeah
yeah he gives a [ __ ] good sense of humor
it doesn't give a [ __ ] and then he goes
like i genuinely like the guy
like i want to see him do well he's like
i just and he would tell him he's like
when they had the live and they were
talking to each other like you could
tell mike perry was a little more
reluctant
yeah but he kind of like it's hard to
not engage
towards the end they were cool yeah no
like cool the whole time i could tell
like mike perry wanted to like just be
like ah [ __ ] it let's go you know like
it'd be cool
but it was just funny to see the dynamic
of him just talking [ __ ] to each other
and then him saying like hey man you
should have won that last fight like
darren till's being real with him he's
like
i don't know how you lost but you just
gotta tighten everything up man like
you could get you could string together
some wins like i don't see why you
couldn't but
well i don't think anybody in that
division is physically as strong as him
yeah he's
nuts like he's a big [ __ ] nut he just
has to take like because
he's what you want out of a fighter
right he's a little crazy he's down
a scrap really tough and he's very
[ __ ] physically strong so it's hard
to [ __ ] too
yeah if you were to just steer him in
the right direction man there's no
there's no telling where he he doesn't
he doesn't seem like he wants to learn
much though like it's hard because
also too i mean not to knock him but
maybe like his iq isn't as
high as everybody else's and you know
yeah i feel like if he ever
happens to listen to this he's just
going to kill me
you you fat asian [ __ ] he's like man
[ __ ] you dude like i'm out here trying
to get some w's for my family that's how
he talks it's just very see that's the
worst though when he when he
puts out a speech and says you know what
i'm in a different mind state now i got
my kid to feed and he puts on the worst
performance
of his life ass whoop so he didn't land
anything on the other guy he didn't do
[ __ ]
he got one takedown where you got to see
his strength literally just grabbed him
and tossed him in the air like
he had moments but it was very one-sided
and yeah but daniel rodriguez the guy he
fought
he fought with a torn peck and was
piecing him up
and just was beating the brakes off him
and daniel rodriguez is
really good bro yeah he's he's like this
guy's gonna be a force to deal with at
170. we'll see what happens his jab is
nuts
is it such a good [ __ ] job dude he
broke his nose again like mike perry's
nose got broke again you know [ __ ] dude
i don't know what he's going to do like
how how is he going to continue to fight
in the sport
he keeps losing he's probably got one
more chance if that
he's like tyron woodley dude tyrone got
nothing left in him anymore either he's
got his ass
lily's got to hang it up dude i think
he's been having to hang it up he's like
what the [ __ ] yeah it was weird like his
i mean i like the fact that he came to
fight
yeah he was cracking he actually wobbled
the [ __ ] out of him yeah
but then he got overzealous and he kept
it's these older fighters they keep
throwing these looping shots
and they have to know now like once they
pick up their timing they just throw a
[ __ ] straight down the middle
and that's it it's over yeah yeah yeah
and it just shows me
like the sport always wins bro yeah like
the longer you stay in the game in the
fight game
you're gonna end up like you're gonna
end up getting knocked out like that's
why habib and
gsp like that's why i'm glad those fools
are out because
like it's unfortunate how the sport is
right it's like you're only as good as
your last fight
like as great as jon jones is right if
he were to fight francis and ganu
and he were to get knocked out he's
literally his only loss
yeah and he would get say he got knocked
out by francis all the fans would be
like
man [ __ ] that jon jones was washed he
was never good he was on his way out
he's trash like like that's how people
kind of are and it sucks so like when
you look at tyron woodley like people
kind of forget that like how good he was
yeah and they also forget that tyler
willie's 39 this year yeah yeah bro old
yeah
the only weight class that people
survive at that age is heavy weight
that's it everybody else specifically in
the welterweight class they start
peeking off at
35 like that's it and they're done yeah
so
the fact that he's still in here at 38
39 still cracking people at that level
is pretty amazing yeah
but his number one people know his
blueprint yeah they know his bloopers
so [ __ ] well and he tried to change
it up this time
but the weird thing about a fighter like
tyron woodley is is that
he only throws looping shots that's
it yeah which is weird he was like well
if i come out more aggressive i could
show people the person that i am
but they know the attack that you're
going to do which is weird because he
talks about his wrestling he talks about
all the other [ __ ] he doesn't go for
shots
yeah he doesn't go for single legs
double eggs or anything yeah i was
and you know luke a2 by the way is a
kickboxing guy i thought he was just
going to take him down and smash his
face in yeah
but she didn't do yeah yeah it was very
weird it was a weird fight yeah some
guys really
like that's what makes um like gsp
the the greats like the the tyron
woodley has all those skills but he just
doesn't for some reason
know how to blend them yeah it's nice
yeah they're very separate
and then you got the guys that know how
to like like mighty mouse right like
that it's just
constantly switching from wrestling the
kickboxing the [ __ ] this to this
like they really keep you on your toes
right so that's like the real special
blend but yeah woodley
like especially as his body's slowing
down too like [ __ ] and you're doing the
separate thing like nah
he's definitely not as fast as he used
to be yeah yeah you could
definitely see it well it's like you
think about how these guys win right
like there's a reason why the gsps and
the habibs are so dominant in the sport
is because the style that they fight
is so controlling yeah you look like
tyron woodley like early in his career
when he was like
like early in the ufc when he was
winning a lot of fights he was just
[ __ ]
blitzkrieg [ __ ] just i would
blow your face off i would crack you
with one and you're dunzo like remember
the jharan
oh yeah the [ __ ] josh kosciek the
darren till you know finish like
and a lot of times too it's like if you
don't have that style in this type of
sport
it's it's really hard to be successful
for a long period of time
like because people will figure you out
they figured out i was like you said
tyrone woodley they figured out his he
has a big
heavy hand and then besides that there's
not much you have to really
like worrying about you know if you put
it in somebody even somebody like kevin
holland the blueprint is there
yeah yeah just take him out just took
one guy like derek brunson and
i'm not saying derek brunson isn't he's
an elite level fighter right
but you see something like arasana that
was successfully stopping his takedowns
you look at someone like kevin holland
he literally didn't know what he was
doing
yeah that was the odd thing you know was
a dc was saying a bunch of like side
commentary but i didn't know what i
don't grapple so i don't know but he was
he was literally pinpointing everything
that he was doing wrong
the reactions weren't there like the
initial reaction when someone grabs you
like fighting the hand stuffing the head
position like you could tell like he was
kind of processing it
and then like oh [ __ ] and then he's on
his back
because i've been there too like i
remember like my second mma fight
i just got taken down not not by a guy
that was a really good wrestler he was
just like a bigger guy
and he had his wrestling was actually
really bad but my wrestling defense was
even worse and
when you when someone grabs you like
that you feel helpless yeah because i
honestly thought i knew how to defend
takedowns but at the time
if i look back on it i'm like oh my god
like the things i did not do
was is just horrendous like you watch
back on it
and it's like it really just shows that
how good you
say you're [ __ ] an eight out of ten
in the gym
when you fight depending on your anxiety
depending on
how who shows up that night you might be
a [ __ ] five out of ten you know like
you know like your skills sometimes
don't really show up the way they're
supposed to especially
if you don't drill those things
constantly if it's not always in the
forefront of your brain
then it's real easy for those skills to
be disliked to almost be kind of
non-existent when you're in those crunch
time situations
i will say this though the fight i
wasn't too impressed with marvin vittori
because i'm i i i know a lot of people
might disagree but
that was a very short notice fight for
kevin holland and on the stand-up game
he was getting [ __ ] up yeah
he was getting [ __ ] up dude like kevin
holland landed
crazy shots on him hard ass shots and
marvin victoria's supposed to be known
as a really great counter-striker
if you if he can't do that to kevin
holland he's not going to do that to
[ __ ] others
in my mind when i watched that fight
to me marvin vittori stock kind of
stayed the same
kevin hollenstalk went up yeah because
you talk about because you're watching
him like all he has to do is just fix
something that
in theory is pretty simple to fix right
like fixing your takedown
it's not easy give them like six months
exactly but for a guy that's as talented
and as a good of a grappler as kevin
holland is and as good of a striker is
you're like once he plugs up those holes
he's going to be pretty tough to deal
with yeah he's just got to do it because
even on joe rogans he was saying like i
hate right he was like i hate wrestling
practice he's like i don't i don't like
doing it i don't know i don't he's like
i don't do it
and then he literally lost to uh derrick
brunson right here
from wrestling look at francis and gano
[Music]
and he was calm patient a lot of faints
bro he had like a striking game
like he he had like he didn't rush
anybody you know i don't see i don't
know who was going to [ __ ] with him
what the [ __ ] was stipe so tiny was it
for speed is that why he kind of decided
to come in smaller i don't know
who knows who knows what happened it was
a very weird look i was like man he
looks extremely small next to ngano in
this fight he got
it's hard to say but like stipe got out
class in that fight
yeah he didn't look like he was it was
competitive at all
yeah unfortunately like well i think he
just expected
too much of the same of the first one
and was kind of like
took him too long to adjust to the the
moves that francis was doing and then it
was just over by the time
he he was trying to do anything i think
the shell shock from getting the
takedown stuffed and then just locked
him up a little bit and
getting offense on him from that sure
yeah that's like
because if you stuff a takedown and it's
like you just pull your leg out
all right i'll be more willing to try it
again but if i shoot for a takedown and
get completely dominated from that
position and
get reversed getting sucked out and
offense is getting rained on me
yeah i'm gonna be thinking twice about
shooting that takedown yeah
because you're giving up like it's not
easy either like
for a big guy like francis to take that
[ __ ] down i mean he had a
really great counter and i think like he
thought that he rocked him and he didn't
oh when he got knocked out that's
exactly yeah because he hits and gandu
and you see ghana kind of take a step
back
and stephen kind of like oh [ __ ] i think
i heard him yeah but he wasn't i don't
think it hurt him
i think he slipped he slipped a little
bit yeah yeah yeah and then
he did hit him but yeah or or whatever
it may be off balance or what but it
looked to him look like oh i wobbled him
and then
you did not knocked nothing out it was
rough bad that was a bad guy
because he was looking for a leaping
hook and it just didn't work out and i'm
like dude francis his feet were planted
i'm like he's gonna reach there before
you are
yeah like if if francis was a smaller
guy that had like crazy ko power
and like like they say the size
difference was switched i'd be like oh
yeah
stipe all day you know but because
francis is not only
just an amazing power puncher but he's
[ __ ] 260
of just lean muscle like that folk could
do mr olympia and probably be
you know what the funniest thing to me
is that stipe is an american but now
francis and gano's english is now better
than steepest
the movie snatch with brad pitt yeah
yeah that's what he sounds like
yeah he's a gypsy dude hate dogs he's
like that stipe uh
what what did you uh prepare for in this
fight i didn't think i'm saying
that bobby boucher oh
yeah okay cool next question i'm like
what the [ __ ] is that
when you i look back at his old videos
it's not even [ __ ] a head trauma
that's just how he talks
that's just it yeah it's weird and
[ __ ] and god who's english is so
[ __ ] good that's really good oh that
guy's an alien dog he's a [ __ ]
he's willing to learn like they didn't
embed it right and then like
it's like a behind-the-scenes vlog of
all the fighters and stuff and then they
did stipe and he just seems like a
normal like all-american dude you know
he's at the firehouse chopping it up
doing pranks with the boys you know
the firehouse boys and you see francis
he's in like this like las
vegas giant home right and he's like
worried he looks like he's about to go
to the club or some [ __ ]
just like a very nice outfit and he's at
home and his private chef
makes him a meal and he sits down and he
eats in the living room and he just
stares off
eats by himself no tv nothing nothing
just sits there and he's just like
looking off and he's eating
and then he walks picks up his bowl
walks back out and you just see this
dude like
interact with the world you know at his
home you're like
that's [ __ ] an alien bro he just sees
zeros and ones
yeah he knows him once yeah and just
thinks about murder
fantasizing his his story on the rogan
podcast
was [ __ ] insane man he's talking
about this intense story but he's
speaking in a monotone voice like yeah
like it's normal
super convoy like he's going to the
store i don't know
but i wake up and i went to the sand
mine because we didn't have any money
then uh i don't know
if you guys are listening out there you
don't know who francis and god knows
francis nagano is now the current
heavyweight champion in the ufc baddest
man
so planet when he was a child he worked
in a sand mine
so i don't know what a [ __ ] sand mine
is right because we need to
mine sand i guess i had no idea that
scent that needed to be mined
i'm like you just santa's just there
yeah right let's go to the [ __ ]
desert it's right there there's plenty
yeah yeah wait why are you digging it up
man so i had to look at
the last thing we needed more of is sand
you know what it is and it's
this like riverbed would just like silt
and sand and they just have a shovel and
it's just francis and gano
just alone what is it before though like
what do they use the same
i don't know like all the stuff that
michaels you know like when you go to
michael's
and then like you buy like fake
artificial sand is that yeah that's what
it is
imagine that's what it's magic france
the guy digging all that [ __ ]
and then just for for someone's arts and
crafts project michael's yeah yeah like
imagine that like
that's [ __ ] up i want to see him go to
michael's pick up a bag and start crying
my family this is a signal a tear driver
his family was like starving and he was
like the man of the household
so like like the age of i'm not don't
quote me on this like 13 or 12.
so you guys quote him on this he started
working in a sand mine and started
digging [ __ ] sand that's so crazy
and digging sand and for a [ __ ]
living to support his family
so i guess from whatever he's from like
in cameroon in order for him to go to
france or something else he had to
traverse a [ __ ] desert
and people who go up more sand dude more
sand
i can't get away from sand he hates the
beach he will never go
i had to dig sand and then for freedom i
had to go into the desert
let's just make david talk like this for
the rest of the time bro i listen to
that podcast so much it was so monotone
but apparently on this desert ride when
he's going into this like sand dune
adventure
half the people die yeah which is
[ __ ] crazy
people people literally fall off the
truck will not stop
if you fall he was like the truck keeps
going he's like if you fall it's like
you die there's like there's
like [ __ ] i guess gary's dead
yeah they're like standing and if you
let go obviously you're dead dead and
they won't go back for you that's it
and there was a part where he was saying
like there's there's mothers with babies
and they're so tired from holding on uh
that the the the women like sometimes
contemplate throwing the babies off
and when she said when he said that the
joe rogan drove was like [ __ ] like what
the [ __ ]
and and and ganu was like it's
understandable though
but it's hard it's very hot
toss that [ __ ] baby
you just i just think your friends was
looking at the lady
hurry up and you know just do it the
arms give it out so
i can tell your arms are very tired just
just do it
just do it you don't want to pass around
like no just kidding if you throw the
baby
i won't tell nobody yeah the phone is
[ __ ]
and it's the truck and you gotta it's
not like a new [ __ ] 20 21
[ __ ] toyota truck oh it's not it's
not right it's like you know it's like a
[ __ ] beat up like
[ __ ] tin like trays we don't know
yeah we don't know if the truck's gonna
make it yeah
yeah if it breaks down you just
everyone's dead everybody's just [ __ ]
hey we die
and then on top of that too he does all
this other [ __ ] somehow ends up in
[ __ ] france and i don't know how
somebody he
either he was what cleaning the gym or
or he wanted to learn how to fight how
did that i don't remember
exactly how that happened he went he was
gonna go into boxing
i think he was gonna go into boxing
that's right and then uh
i don't know where he stayed he was
illegal i think right and then
there was some situation where he they
were gonna they couldn't license him for
boxing but they could
for mma and he was like i'll just i just
want to start fighting and he just went
in there started murdering [ __ ]
if you look at his first fights in the
ufc you could tell he is
fresh like he does not know how to fight
most heavyweights are apparently
like oh like tai toivasa he had like two
years of fighting before he went to the
ufc and like
you could tell how much different he
looks from the beginning of his career
which is like
four fights ago to like now and you're
like oh this guy's a lot fresh like he's
he's he's a little tighter now and so is
francis
francis
is so like francis he was raw bro like
when he came into the ufc
yeah he was like oh if i hit you once
you're out bang let's see if you look at
his first fights
his footwork is terrible yeah no
footwork he's just lumbering around
trying to throw him running at
[ __ ] exactly and people don't
know what to [ __ ] do he has the
hardest
recorded punch in the world i think
that's crazy dude like on one of them
hit one of those like arcade [ __ ]
things and
no that's scientific bro okay i want
your mouth that's not science no it's
not it's not
it's a 999.99 yeah it went to 999.
i don't know i don't know yeah the voice
that was my favorite thing that he kept
saying on the podcast i don't know
it makes for a good podcast yeah well i
the ufc is like street fighter dude
it literally is like the game street
like they just get the best
you know like that it's so wild to me
that literally these people would have
like stipe and ganu literally would have
never met
ever in boxing in the world no in any
way
it's real life blood sports it's like
it's real like these people like you get
dudes from brazil that would have never
fought these dudes from the uk
but because of this organization they
literally it's so [ __ ] crazy to me
that
talk about like a sport that's more
worldwide than the ufc like than mma
like there's not many soccer mma yeah
soccer's not very international though
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
very international at all there's no
dagger standing people that play soccer
bro you know what i mean because this
will pick they'll pick it up with their
hand and start throwing it in the
[ __ ]
right they start wrestling right now
you're saying basketball is the most
ridiculous thing i've ever seen in my
life yeah look up
if you're at home look up some dagger
standing a lot of traveling going on
traveling
zero dribbling yeah no no dribbling you
play with kyrie irving people yeah you
play with kyrie
and they're double leggings they're just
tackling people in [ __ ] mid-air dude
yeah it's [ __ ] nuts yeah and that's
that i guess that's how it goes
brutal dude their wrestling's so legit
they're scott damn bro
you know [ __ ] like when i when i was
going through like the ngano story
have you guys even heard of the dmx life
story have you read anything about it no
not really dude his personal life story
is
[ __ ] insane it's probably the saddest
thing i heard about how
he got hooked on uh like drugs and how
he started like
yeah so he so i mean he was a pretty
like
he lived a pretty [ __ ] up life right
like i there's so much information i
have to paraphrase this unless i read it
off the page because it's so specific
but his relationship with his mom
obviously his dad wasn't around
but his mom was like hyper abusive
towards him
like if i kind of read the kind of [ __ ]
that she would say to him because he
wrote it in his autobiography it's
[ __ ] terrible
but he he was 13 and he had he got some
weed
from an older homie who was like his
brother like he looked up to this guy
right
and he laced his [ __ ] like on training
day yeah and that's how he got hooked on
drugs wow and apparently he got him into
rap too right like that yeah so he
he was rapping and um that that became
his his mentor because they saw promise
in him right
yeah and so he he went through barking
all the time
have you heard [ __ ] dmx do anything
when dmx speaks he speaks like how he
raps
yeah it's [ __ ] weird yeah it's just
the same it's great the reading rainbow
thing you posted the reading did you see
that [ __ ]
did you see oh yeah yeah reading rainbow
they they dubbed it and they i forgot
what's up
dmx reading rainbow right now it's the
best it's the best i saw this in middle
school
the best thing i've ever seen and it
goes kind of well like
it it's it's like sick it's like oh
really
yeah suck my dude
[Music]
my [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
this is
when you listen to like dmx's music you
realize how much the n-word was used
back in the day yeah well i can
never say sing any of his songs anymore
the music is so different like
the way he used to rap is so different
than like a typical rapper nowadays like
well he had you can't really find any
rappers that raps like him
in today's era i don't think even back
like he had his own yeah
he was just like coming at you like
yelling the whole [ __ ] i don't think
he never wasn't yelling or i guess he
would go into those little whispers and
then yell
he was like a master
the god talk about him and he's
apparently he was really close with him
and he was telling some funny ass
stories and his whole thing was like
he goes that full dmx wouldn't change
who he was for anybody like
whether he had millions of dollars or
whether he was dead broke or coming out
of jail he was the same [ __ ] bro
and they were saying like there was a
story about him they had they were like
out clubbing or some [ __ ]
and he had to take a [ __ ] and it was
like late at night and he was trying to
go to like some someone's like
place and he goes hey you you could take
a [ __ ] in there but i don't got toilet
paper he goes oh yeah that's cool
he goes in the ship takes his [ __ ] and
he goes yo i gotta take a [ __ ] dog like
ghost takes a [ __ ]
and it leaves he goes i'm gonna shower
anyway like it's all good like let's get
the [ __ ] out of here
like and he would just do [ __ ] like that
like he's just kind of like i'm not
gonna shower anyways no he said i'm
gonna shower afterwards but he goes i
don't need to wipe that's why i gotta
take a shot i gotta take a [ __ ]
he's just hood as [ __ ] he don't get that
[ __ ] like he just i got no toilet paper
i don't give a [ __ ] i'll just wipe with
my hands
let me just read some of the [ __ ] that
he went through because you guys have to
hear this [ __ ] man
like damn it it's gonna kind of make you
sad because i guess he had like a pretty
crazy oh that's that's different let's
see dmx
nude we'll see dmx turn agony and atomic
energy
into one of rap's most titanic legacies
let me just read some of this [ __ ] those
bars like i had to read this in part
because it made me hella sad like just
his life
beatings were habitual misbehaving meant
his mother her boyfriends and sometimes
the mailman would reign blows
mailman why the [ __ ] they're just the
mailman
neighborhoods jumping this kid yeah what
part of the story
where the mailman came in and was like i
gotta [ __ ] this kid up yeah
so it's okay the mom i'm picturing the
mom hidden beating his ass the boyfriend
getting some kicks in the mailman comes
to draw
like i miss i have mail and she's like
no you come in here beat this fool's ass
and he's like
all right or or
the mailman comes in he's like yo what
the [ __ ] you guys doing like chill
and then the little dmx is like me [ __ ]
you and he goes in he's all right i'm
gonna start beating him
with some money yeah
we delivering these blows today
the mailman would rain down blows with
belts extension cords
shout out to the extension cord beating
i hated that [ __ ] yeah hangers and
brooms and i know for a fact when my
parents were whipping with me with an
extension cord
they definitely learned it from the
store that was not a korean thing
sometimes she cursed him out by
screaming you ain't [ __ ] just like your
father
talk this is just the beginning of his
[ __ ] life his father barker was
largely absentee an artist who painted
watercolors of street scenes to sell at
local fairs and malls very sweet his
dad's name was
parker or barker his dad's name was
barker of course
which oh dude right isn't that crazy
it's full circle bro
so early iq tests showed that his
intelligence was higher than most kids
two and three grades higher report cards
from the time described him as highly
bright and manipulative
see that's also a problem too right like
especially like when you grow in a
very like troubled area they don't know
what to do with smart kids
they think sometimes that when kids are
really smart they see them as defiant
they're too smart yeah
they think that they're defiant they
think that they're disruptive but what
actually happens is with a lot of these
kids who are really smart and i'm this
is from information from my friends who
are teachers it's like
they're actually just really they're a
little bit ahead yeah so
testing boundaries and so when adults
have a younger child who they're
supposed to be smarter than questions
their authority
they take it as a personal hit they go
oh this kid's being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah but sometimes the kid is just
asking why that's true though right
because it's like
when you ask a lot of questions like
that sometimes it is frowned upon like
people just want
sheep sometimes like just like hey just
be easy just listen what i have to tell
you to do just do it you'll be fine come
on
and it's hard to when you're when you're
[ __ ] broke as [ __ ] too and you're
just
trying to make ends meet the last thing
you want is your kid to [ __ ] ask you
why
they're [ __ ] up yeah right they're
doing something they go hey clean up
your room
why do i have to clean up my room well
because i'm going to beat you with an
extension cord
all right and the mailman's going to
come tomorrow morning and whoop your
[ __ ] ass
rain down some blows
daddy's right now painting some [ __ ]
watercolors but the mailman's gonna whip
your ass tomorrow
you better watch the [ __ ] out it's like
a clifford the the red dog story but
like just the negative version of it
where the whole community comes together
just beat his ass too
the bakers come out and [ __ ] them up the
janitors like the whole
everyone has a turn whooping this fool's
ass so check this out about that clip
for the ring
so all this [ __ ] passes watch this so
this he gets a little older
and they kind of go through some more
you know trials and tribulations that he
went through so following yet another
expulsion for bad behavior he got
expelled from school
his mother took her 10 year old son dmx
on a surprise visit to check out the
children's
village group home led to believe that
he was merely
inspecting the premises she entered him
into the institution
so she [ __ ] tricked this kid doesn't
have a heart-to-heart conversation and
draws him off and says here you go
you're you're not my problem anymore at
the age of [ __ ] 10
so from that point on he started having
trust issues he goes oh this is how the
world is
like i can't even trust my mom i can't
trust any my dad's not around
his mom [ __ ] left him at a [ __ ]
group home that's cool
dude so he said in his book right then i
learned to pull away conceal and bury
whatever bothered me
the other side of me was born here the
side that that enabled me to protect
myself
but dude this is this is him only at the
age of 10.
this is [ __ ] crazy dude yeah imagine
seeing a 10 year old like that like
that's [ __ ]
so check this [ __ ] out several months
later he and another child would be
arrested for
arson in his defense he claimed that he
didn't want to set the school on fire
just to see if the flames would turn
blue
this [ __ ] hey see my boy's
curious
he's he's just trying to if someone give
this kid a bunsen burner bro
if he had a bunsen burner he wouldn't
have burned on the whole sometimes
flames are blue
and it's confusing you gotta you gotta
get to the bottom yeah i want to know
only way to figure it out is you gotta
light some [ __ ] on fire you wanna hear
them all
watch the [ __ ] though so soon after he
nearly killed his co-conspirator leading
the
leading to the group home to isolate him
in the infirmary yeah because he
he nearly killed his coach he tried to
kill the dude that he that he was
burning the pla the
trying to pull arsenal in the in the
[ __ ] group because it was his idea
and he said what the [ __ ] man you got me
in trouble i don't want to do that
he's [ __ ] pen he's smart hey loki
he's smart
he's a smart kid how do you try to kill
him he just like tried to stab him or
some [ __ ]
the mailman drops off mail for the group
on me like yo [ __ ] this fool up yeah
he never had a song about like [ __ ] the
post office
yeah like where's that song dude [ __ ]
the u.s mail post like no lying about it
nosy [ __ ] daniel
like where's the song about the [ __ ]
[ __ ] business you never heard of a
song called [ __ ] fedex
[ __ ] with fedex only first-class ass
woman hey you don't look at his mail at
all he's like two traumatized yeah
yeah every time he saw a mailman he had
to be true like
that'd be beautiful oh hey it goes back
to the dog thing bro
oh parker barker he
barked dogs hate [ __ ] natural enemies
so check this out so after 18 months dmx
returned home despising his family life
he started spending the night on the
streets
sleeping in salvation army clothing bins
[ __ ] crazy
and then befriending stray dogs
he's the man what the [ __ ] this is like
a villain origin story
that's what i'm saying like this doesn't
sound real this is like the joke crazy
yeah i haven't even seen it but so a
regionally respected rapper this is the
guy that we were talking about named
ready ron offered early mentorship and
encouraged him to take the art seriously
he also allegedly introduced him to
cocaine in the form of a woolly
a cocaine lace blunt that the 14 year
old dmx mistakenly believed to be
strictly weed
so it's like that that whole trust issue
that he has right so he has this guy
that his [ __ ] mentor
his mom told him that he they were going
to visit this place and it turns out
that it's a group home that she left him
at for 18 [ __ ] months wow he meets
his
older brother figure who's supposed to
watch after him [ __ ] gives him an
example bro burns him too
this fool just constantly has trust
issues throughout his whole life
oh he couldn't blame the kid man yeah so
as a freshman x became the second
fastest on the varsity varsity track
team damn he's [ __ ] talented
competing in spite of his grades and
sparse attendance record but he was
broke hungry and looked raggedy in
hand-me-downs
neither his mother nor his grandmother
had the money to help him the way of the
gun became his preferred route his first
victim was a lady walking out of a
supermarket in yonkers getty square
jumping out the bushes he snatched the
purse off her shoulder and sprinted away
the score netted him a thousand dollars
in cash so he started robbing people at
that point while he was trying to become
a [ __ ] rapper
yeah so this dude is just as [ __ ]
gutter as possible like has absolutely
no options no [ __ ] money no support
from his mom his grandma his grandpa his
dad is absentee
and at this point he's robbing people
doing like dirty [ __ ] just to get
[ __ ] money
yeah wow damn so if we just skip forward
to his nuts so those
those years from 1986 so see he said
that there was something kind of
peaceful thing about me so he got locked
up
quite a few times oh [ __ ] yeah he'd been
in jail
he wasn't didn't he go to jail for tax
evasion too yeah that was not too long
ago though that was like recently
yeah and then i heard he checked into
rehab after that so my man has just been
like
a hard life bro and like when you hear
these stories it's like
you know some people they try to like
they try to like look down
on people that have troubled childhood
and stuff like that and it's like
when you hear these stories it provides
a lot more context to see
where these where people came from and
how they ended up this way
like people don't end up people just
don't go out robbing people for no
reason just because you know
hey man like yeah it's very complicated
that was the biggest thing biggest life
lesson i learned probably
in through the pandemic right because i
haven't seen a lot of my
a lot of my friends in a while right
yeah and there's certain friends now
that you start to kind of sift out and
you see that they're kind of either
annoying or maybe you don't really like
them as much
yeah but during the pandemic i kind of
started piecing together all these
stories that they were telling me about
their personal lives and like
that's why you're so [ __ ] up because
your [ __ ] parents like your parents
created this environment for you the
only difference is that they haven't
recognized that yet right
yeah so i think a lot of people do this
stuff where
they start to display in the world for
everything else besides looking inward
and seeing like for sure
what the [ __ ] happened in my life that's
allowed me to have these bad [ __ ]
behaviors right
like specifically i've been seeing a lot
of my friends who've had um uh
parental like they don't have two parent
figures around they are the ones
in my personal opinion and i'm saying
this about like
maybe 10 or 11 people that i know that
have uh
trust issues in their relationships
because they don't they see somebody who
has either left them early on
or their parental figure whether it was
a man or a woman in their life
wasn't the best example of a human being
yeah so they have this and
you know dmx has that to the [ __ ]
extreme yeah yeah yeah
why why wouldn't you yeah like this dude
has like if you were to put that in a
movie you'd be like
that's [ __ ] bro get the [ __ ] out of
here but the fact that like
this [ __ ] happens probably way more than
people could even imagine
you know and it's like it's funny that
you say that too because during the
pandemic it's like
recently i don't know this is just
because i'm getting a little older and
i'm starting to piece certain things
together
but you start to realize that the
tendencies and like the way you react to
certain things or
it's all like learned from when you were
a kid and like you
you piece together like when you hear
other people's stories about how they
grew up as
with their parents stuff you start to
realize like oh [ __ ] like
well i was telling that [ __ ] [ __ ] me up
so i was telling nick that there's a
friend of mine who um
they have so the husband and wife have a
very interesting relationship when i say
interesting it's very volatile right
so there's like this weird dynamic that
they have when they also have this child
around
so what i started noticing recently was
how
you know and from an outside perspective
i can't come up and tell
them what the [ __ ] they're doing wrong
my personal opinion number one i don't
have kids and it's not my place
and i don't have that trust relationship
where i can lay my opinion like that on
something that i'm not involved in right
but just from an outside perspective
just watching them for a few days it was
kind of like
oh there's certain behaviors that
um she doesn't like in the husband that
the the kid is now picking up from the
husband
yeah right so that that
i'm literally seeing what i didn't
notice when i was a kid right
because my dad when i when he we had
this huge fight back in the day but he
was telling me like
my biggest flaw is that i he is that i
thought
i always thought that i was better than
him but he doesn't he goes you don't
realize that you're just a nut you're
just a better version of me
right so yeah you are better than some
of these bad tendencies
that i have but you still do the same
[ __ ] that i do because i raised you yeah
you know
yeah and so i'm seeing that now in their
son
to the father yeah where it's a trip
it's it's a weird thing i
literally see a mirror image now yeah so
all the bad behavior quote-unquote bad
behaviors that she says that she doesn't
like in
in the husband yeah i'm seeing it in
their kid now oh where the kid is over
apologetic or he he kind of like
stutters his words or whatever i'm like
holy [ __ ] you sound just like your
[ __ ] dad
that's so crazy yeah it really is monkey
see monkey do with kids
they really do look at you and like they
even the thing you don't because you
because even with my daughter like
at first i thought it was like all about
like the things you say to them time
whatever
but even the little things when you do
something like even if you're frustrated
like
cooking something or whatever like or
they pick up on all
all that energy like they're absorbing
everything dude
like they literally absorb like little
mannerisms all the every all the vibes
everything so if you have a house where
[ __ ] are fighting like
they're picking up on all that [ __ ] for
real and and like for me like i grew up
like my parents
like they were divorced young they got
together broke up got together broke up
and i kind of mirrored that in my own
relationships i was in a lot of
relationships that were on and off on
and off
but they used to fight when i was little
and stuff like that but i mean yeah
it's that's definitely not good if that
was the thing you were going to tell
your your friend to be like hey stop
fighting in front of the kid
yeah i'm telling you you you are you
have more than a right to say that
because
that is the right [ __ ] thing to say
because it's not good cut that [ __ ] out
man you can't fight in the other [ __ ]
room or wait till the kid's not around
you know because it does [ __ ] with kids
it does because that becomes your normal
right like for my parents like too like
the way they would talk to each other
for a really long time
like i realized i was like oh this is
not
okay like for a while i used to think it
was normal like oh that's how people do
it
and then as i got older i was like oh
wait this is not ideal
so it can either go the flip like the
flip side right for me i was like in my
head i don't know
i didn't like consciously think this at
least i i thought but
i remember thinking i was like i don't
ever want to have a relationship like my
mom and dad
ever so i made it very apparent in my
life where
with my current partner my lady like i
made sure that like okay we're not gonna
do
any of that [ __ ] so anytime something
would get anywhere close to that i'd be
like
nah we're shutting that [ __ ] down this
is not the way it's gonna be
and but then again on the other side of
that then you pick up some of these
other tendencies where i'm realizing
myself that like
my parents would do that until somebody
else brings it up or
from someone else's different
perspective that's like a little bit or
someone else's experience that's
similar like they'll tell me about it i
was like oh [ __ ]
like i'd be kind of doing that same [ __ ]
too like you know
it's crazy and i'm starting to realize a
lot more of these tendencies and
it's kind of it's a lot better to help
you kind of like
okay how do i try to fix it it doesn't
happen overnight it's a process and
there's a lot of weird things that you
that you kind of normalize that you
think it's okay because you just saw
your whole life like yeah
this is kind of this isn't terrible but
it to me it's funny now
so in my household it was it was like
destructive like my dad would kick down
doors yeah if you go i could take you
through a walk through through my house
in sacramento and i'll show you every
[ __ ] hole that everybody punched in
the house yeah
because people will get frustrated you
can't communicate well you don't do that
stuff david no i do not
i do not you don't do none of that i
don't do none of that no most no no
no no no so marielle and i when we first
started going out
you know our communication was [ __ ]
terrible we just didn't know how to
speak to each other everybody
it was just two separate languages and
it would get to the point where mario
would like push my buttons on purpose to
get a reaction out of me and my response
out of anger because i would see my
parents do it
i would start busting [ __ ] like i was
just like yo what the [ __ ]
because i also never been with the woman
who would push my buttons on purpose
yeah
the first woman and she happens to be
korean i love you
so i i remember so we got into a fight
and i got [ __ ] mad and this was in
our apartment and it was something very
small it was a little bottle of creme
a little creme bottle creme right and
she got me so mad i just [ __ ] chucked
it i smashed it to the floor right
this little bottle but she stopped and
she looked at me and she started tearing
up and i'm like
in my mind i'm like i'm gonna hit you
[ __ ] what you crying for yeah
when i saw that i was like dave you're
so different you know she got she got
scared i'm like the [ __ ] you scared
about like things happening here i'm
i'm angry so i'm breaking [ __ ] and she's
like you can't do that
like that scares me i'm like scared yeah
bro i'm gonna hit you like
i would never hit you it doesn't [ __ ]
matter for real like the violent action
scared the [ __ ] [ __ ] out i was like
wait
this is normal yeah this is how normal
people come from
dude that's what i thought too yeah i've
had a moment like that where i'm just
like ah
and she's like yo chill and i'm like
that's okay
and it hits you like from that point on
now i don't [ __ ] throw [ __ ] or break
things when i get mad yeah yeah or you
know we don't even fight like that
anymore thank god yeah but
they'd be squabbing but they don't like
argue you know now we just put on gloves
100 to the body 10 to the face 10 second
bodies bro you know that second body
let me tell you this [ __ ] funny [ __ ]
right so after that fight
a few months later we got into another
fight right and i'm talking about shits
boiling over
i forgot what she said to me i forgot
what i said to her but either way [ __ ]
was about to go down
yeah and i'm getting [ __ ] mad right
about some cream and i have my phone and
i'm about to [ __ ] chuck this [ __ ]
but then i remembered how scared she got
over the little creme
so what i did i was like god damn it and
i had this uh [ __ ] a windbreaker and
i unzipped it and i was like
[ __ ] and i threw the windbreaker and
then it caught so much when it just
popped in the air
and this [ __ ] laughed at me she [ __ ]
laughed at me right in my face
she was like what was that i'm like it
took like 10 seconds to follow the
ground
i was like this was so unsatisfying and
this woman's laughing at me
she doesn't respect you yeah i feel so
embarrassed
i bet that was a good tension breaker
though it was we stopped fighting after
but i wanted to
[ __ ] kill
[Laughter]
i remember that moment i was so
embarrassed yeah and i still can't live
it now i'm getting angry right now
just thinking about it nah that ain't
that bad bro it's terrible when you're
there it's a windbreaker that's funny
that's cool
it's like when you play [ __ ] batman
then you hit that stupid wiffle ball and
it just stops yeah
he goes that's exactly what it felt like
damn bro
shut a shuttle a shuttle [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] full circle baby bang bang bang
bang bang bang bang bang bang bang put
her fingers in my butt i'm like nah
that happened you let it happen don't
lie i swear i don't you know i'm not
ready for that
i can't do butt play bro yeah but plays
my dad bro you just said you're gonna
get [ __ ] in the ass what are you in
this hypothetical scenario bro
i think you're ready for it bro yeah i
think if if if there was never a time i
didn't feel like tip out of strap
on thank you would you let her you know
no luck
i feel like it was very important to her
i think and i wanted i feel like tiff
just takes her finger and just does a
fingerprint scan on your butthole
yeah like skin it opens up
and it's it just engulfs her finger an
enemy what the [ __ ] is this
your [ __ ] don't do that absolutely
it just eats when he eats baby girls
always trying to play with the
[ __ ] bubbles does mario do credit
card to your butthole
she doesn't do any stuff like that in
fact we haven't had sex yet
wow which is why we got into a fight and
i threw that jacket
poppy i'm safe with you just let me see
your [ __ ]
and it opened up she goes and that's why
i don't show you my [ __ ]
but then afterwards she was like okay
okay well everybody that wraps up this
episode of the jesus christ
you guys get what you get you know what
i mean okay what you'll get because
today the pod ends
but uh you guys could catch nick at nick
the ear and then you can find patrick
patrick.t dot riley
stay tuned for his next stand-up shows
and then watch
how [ __ ] he's gonna skyrocket up
there dude
skyrocket all the way he's the white
patrice o'neal oh
dude wow that's a big [ __ ] statement
yeah his name is patrick
and you know it's halfway there you're
kind of irish too right yeah
kind of a little bit well we'll see you
guys every thursday and sundays and
we'll catch you all next time
peace